and now the nominees for achievement in
sound editing American sniper Alan
Robert Murray and bub Osmond Birdman or
the unexpected virtue of ignorance
Martina Landers and Erin Glasgow The
Hobbit the Battle of the five armies
Brent Burge and Jason cannabis
interstellar Richard King unbroken
Becky Sullivan and Andrew DeCristofaro
and the Oscar goes to American sniper
thank you to the Academy first of all to
mr. Clint Eastwood it's always been an
honor and a privilege to work with you
you are the best to Roth Lorenz Bradley
Cooper and the entire Mel Paso team
thank you for your inspiration and your
support to kim law and the warner
brothers family to my family at home
Debbie blue Kevin and Haley thank you I
love you and to our incredible sound
team we want to mention a few people
that we just really wouldn't be up here
without key crew members Jason King
Thomas an itch Katie wood and Michael
Dressel and to my family Jackie Andy and
bill love you guys
thank you very